welcome back in the previous video we
had this very uh
positive scenario where i had originally
bought a house for a million and a half
dollars but then a year later
the value of the house or at least my
perceived value of the house went up to
a 1.5 million because my neighbor sold
their identical house for 1.5 million
dollars and so my initial equity
investment went from 250 000 to 750. and
why is that well equity is nothing but
if i have an asset that's worth a
million and a half and i owe 750 that
was 750 000 that was my original
mortgage on that asset then what i'm
left with is the equity so my equity
just tripled it went from 250 000 to 750
000. in this video what i'm going to do
is i'm going to show you well what does
what can you do with that equity i mean
it's not cash it's kind of like this
make believe amount of wealth that you
have you just feel richer and i'll show
you that you can actually turn it into
cash using something called a home
equity loan and and i'd argue that this
is actually what drove our economy from
about uh
2002 to
probably still to this day although i
think we're in a recession now in fact
i'm about 100 sure we are but
definitely until about 2006.
so what's a home equity loan well i i go
to the bank and i say wow bank i have
all this this i have the 750 000 of
equity i wish you know i'm rich but i
don't have this in cash i want to you
know do something that with equity i
would like to live like a rich person
well the bank says sal you know you're
right um you know our only requirement
is that you have two hundred fifty
thousand dollars uh uh
our only requirement is that you have
twenty five percent equity in your house
right because they want a cushion in
case you can't pay and they get the
house back and they have to foreclose an
auction off the house et cetera et
cetera so they said well
so we're willing to loan up to 75
percent of the value of your house so
what's 75 of the value of my house so
let's see 1.5
times 75 percent
let's see
it'd be 750 000 plus half of 750 000
it'll be
1.0
i think 1.075 million i did that in my
head it could be wrong but it's roughly
the right number so the bank says you
know what
i'm willing to we're willing to lend you
up to 75 of the value of your asset
and it's of course going to be
guaranteed by this asset
so far we lent you 750 000 so you have
let's see how much you have more that
you can borrow from us
minus that's we're talking a million so
it's 0.7075
so that's what 300 is 250
plus 75 so up to 325 000 more
that you could borrow
and what is this what am i where am i
taking this money out of well i'm
essentially taking this money
out of the equity of my house and and
how does that make sense well what's
going to happen
well
i still have
a 1.5 let's say i take this loan let's
say i say bank great
i want
000 of cash
i want it right now
so what happens let me draw another
series of
another balance sheet
i've stopped using the word balance
sheet even though that was the original
purpose of this whole discussion
draw a little bit bigger
remember liabilities plus equities are
equal to assets
i always whenever i draw anyway so what
are my assets now
so now i have a
i have a 1.5 million dollar house
and i also got three hundred twenty-five
thousand dollars cash from the bank so
we could call that let's say 325.
325 okay
cash
got it from the bank now what are my
liabilities well i have the original
mortgage on my house
the original mortgage
the original mortgage is 750 000
dollars this is liabilities on this side
well not the whole side we're gonna have
equity down here so just this is
liability 350 000 and then i took a new
loan to get this 325 000 of cash so i
have a new loan here
about this that amount
325 and this was a home equity loan
i took a loan against the equity that i
have in my house this was the equity in
my house so what's the leftover equity
so let me just make everything clear
these are the liabilities
these are assets
and equities what you have left over so
what are my assets i have one point
one point
what the 825
million in assets
minus now what are my liabilities minus
one
point
let's see
oh seven five right that was the max
that i could borrow
liabilities right assets my assets minus
liabilities is owner's equity
so let's see 8 25
minus 75
i still have 750 000 of equity
and that makes sense if i just enter
into some transaction where i get cash
in exchange for debt my equity shouldn't
change
but now what does happen
well i have this cash and i'm i'm
feeling rich because i've never seen
numbers like seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars and that neighbor that
new neighbor that just bought that house
across uh right next door for 1.5
million dollars he just bought a
beautiful new hummer and and being a
very down to earth person i feel that i
also deserve a hummer like my neighbor
because i am just as rich as they are so
i decide to go out and i i'm going to
spend a hundred thousand dollars
on the hummer
actually let's not do a hummer because a
hummer could actually be con considered
an acid i want to i want pure
consumption although i think a hummer's
pretty close as a car gets to pure
consumption let's say that neighbor went
on a round the world vacation for a
hundred thousand dollars and i too
because i did nothing but sit on my
house and made five hundred thousand
dollars last year i feel that
i also deserve a hundred thousand dollar
vacation so what i do is i take
a hundred thousand dollars of this cash
so i'm now left with just 225
and i have the great experience of going
on a vacation but of course i didn't get
any asset in return for that although
you could maybe your happiness maybe is
an asset i don't know but it doesn't
show up on your balance sheet so we took
we had 325 in cash now we have 225 in
cash so our total liabilities
go down by a hundred thousand so if our
total i'm sorry our total assets went
down by a hundred thousand what are our
assets now it's
one
point seven two five right because we
spent a hundred thousand dollars of our
cash
so what's going to be the liabilities
and equity well the liabilities won't
change right just because i want a
vacation the bank's not going to say hey
sal you owe us less money you i still
owe though almost you know what 1.075
million dollars that hundred thousand
dollars is going to come all out of my
equity
so now all of a sudden
i don't have 750 000
i only have
i only have 650 000
and you could do it and this isn't the
balance sheet just for my house this is
kind of my whole personal balance sheet
and now my whole personal balance sheet
what just happened
i just took some of that original equity
that i had i took a hundred thousand
dollars of it turned into cash and just
went on a great one-year long vacation
and this is what home equity loans are
and this is what i would argue drove the
economy or at least took us into an
expansionary stage from 2000 to 2003
because if you remember a lot of people
were still getting laid off in 2002 2003
but consumer spending kept going up so
if people are earning less money or they
don't even have a job how is spending
going up well the values of the house
went up and they borrowed against the
value of their house they took cash out
of it and they used that cash to buy
their hummers to
to go on vacation to buy you know fancy
clothes or whatever and that drove the
economy
and in the next video i'll actually talk
about maybe
why those housing prices go up
or why they went up in particular during
this housing boom this this one that
we're definitely in the process of
getting out of see in the next video